بين مؤيدا ومعارض موضوع يثير الجدل حول ما
يطلق عليهن اعلاميا فتيات التيك توك
الفتيات يواجهن احكاما وعقوبات مغلطه
تندرج تحت مسمى قانون مكافحه الجرائم
الالكترونيه تشتد العقوبه بالاعتداء على
المبادئ او القيم الاسريه هناك من يرى
ضروره لانقاذ هؤلاء الفتيات مقيما دعوات
طالب بالغاء وتجميد ماده القيم الاسريه
معتبرها فضفاضه الطرف الاخر يشدد على
ضروره وجود مثل هذه القوانين
[موسيقى]
بقانون المصري معمول بها منذ س لماذا الان
قررت انك ترفع دعوه لالغاء هذه الماده
بدعوه او بحجه انها فضفاضه لانها تستغل يا
فندم من قبل طيور الظلام ومن قبل اصحاب
القيم الاسلاميه الرجعيه هذه الماده
للاسفاء استخدامها
لاصدار اتهامات تعود بنا الى عصور القرون
الوسطى الى عصور محاكم التفتيش يتم
التنكيل بفتيات لاجل لا شيء الفتيات ما
بيعملوش حاجه غير انهم يعني بيقلدوا الفن
والتراث المصري الاصيل بيقلده ما يشاهدوه
على قنوات ماسبيرو يقلده ما يشاهدوه في
الافلام التراثيه المصريه اللي كل الشعب
بيفخر بيها وبيحبها فطبعا
للاستغلال هذه الماده يعني تتحدث عن هذا
المحتوى للبنات بينشروه معناته انت موافق
عليه لانه يعني ولا شيء سوى
انعكاس لتراث مصري عريق بكل تاكيد يعني
كلها الفتيات ما بيعملوش حاجه لو شاهدنا
لو جبنا قنوات التلفزيون الحكومي نفس
الشيء طيب يعني عندنا الفنانات المصريات
الرائعات برده بيعملوا كانوا بيعملوا نفس
هذه الحركات نفس هذه الملابس هو اللي
حضرتك على حاجه احنا هنروح بعيد ليه للاسف
هذه القيم المزعومه هي طبعا قيام في اتفاض
احنا مش عارفين هل هي قيم الاسلامويين ولا
قيم السلفيين ولا قيم الرجعيين ولا قيم
مصر الستينات ولا قيم مصر في السبعينات
ولا قيم الطبقات الراقيه في المنتجعات
المصريه قيم الساحل الشمالي ولا قيمه شرم
الشيخ خلينا نسمع استغلالها للتنكيل
بالفتيات دكتور هاني خلينا نسمع
الاستاذ محمود البدوي استاذ محمود شايفك
بتضحك ليه تحياتي يا فندم صباح الخير اهلا
اكيد لان للاسف الشديد مؤ طبعا احنا
ابتولينا ابتلينا بعدد من الدعاوى اللي هي
بتنم عن جهل بفلسفه القانون وفلسفه
التشريع وان كمان يعني سالني ان انا اسمع
في حديث ضيفك الكريم بتوجه اليه طبعا
بالتحيه ان هو بيعمل عمليه قياس خاطئ على
ان ما يقدم من خلال قنوات التيك توك او
بعد القنوات الخاصه على التيك توك وبعض
الامور اللي خرجت علينا وهي هجينه على
المجتمع ودخيل على المجتمع بيقيسها بالفن
المصري القديم اللي هو يعني
الدكتور هاني بيقول هي موجوده احنا يعني
لماذا نكون مثل النعامه
لا اجادل في ان الرقص موجود لا اجدد في ان
رقص موجود ولا اجادل في دور الفن في
الارتقاء بالاخلاق والذوق في المجتمع
المصري ولكن خليني اتكلم عن الفن المسؤول
الفن الذي يحافظ على القيم مش النهارده
اللي كان فيه واحده فيه بتتكلم بتقول
سريرك مسرحك وتكشف الدعاوى وتكشف
التحقيقات النيابه العامه الموقره عن ان
الامر كان على تماس مع جريمه استغلال
البشر والاتجار بالبشر بهذا امر مرفوض
[موسيقى]